>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Leonard Bernstein: Amy is a 2009
Pulitzer finalist in feature writing
and a 2011 winner of the
Pulitzer Prize in feature writing.
She is also utterly fearless
in certain situations,
including her job interview
for the Post two years ago.
When she was telling the editor
in chief and the managing editor
about her attempts to track
down Frank Sinatra in Hollywood.
And in order to find Mr.
Sinatra, she stalked, my word,
Milton Berle to his
lunch engagement.
And got him as he was coming
out, asked him a few questions,
didn't learn anything
particularly too important.
But during her job interview
she jumped to her feet
and she did her Milton
Berle impression.
Amy got the job anyway,
and we have worked together
for the last two years,
utterly delightful to do that.
Amy's written three books,
"Shadows Bright As Glass",
"The Teenage Brain",
and the one you're here
to hear her speak about
"Becoming Nicole."
So, please welcome Amy Eliss Nutt.
[ Applause ]
>> Amy Ellis Nutt: Thank you, Lenny,
and thank you to his brother Neal,
Neal Bernstein who without him
I'm sure I would not be here.
I just want to clarify
about Milton Berle.
He was a good friend
of Frank Sinatra's,
and I thought maybe Milton would
know where he was, how he was doing,
if he was alive, if
he was compos mentis.
And the valet people at
The Friars Club said,
yeah he's always here at noon.
And his car picks him up at one.
You know, he comes from this
door and gets right into his car.
So, I thought, geez I'm only
going to have 30 seconds most
and what I didn't realize,
and this was my impression,
was Milton Berle was
about 102 at this point.
And when he came out, if, you know,
Milton Berle, if you're old enough,
in his trench coat with a
cigar, this was Milton Berle.
I don't know how you sign
that, but you don't have to.
You don't have to.
The beauty of that was I had
about an hour and a half.
And he gave me give information.
He had just spoken to Frank.
Frank was compos mentis,
so my job was done.
Back to New Jersey.
Anyway, I'm thrilled to be here.
My sister kept saying, "Oh,
there's going to be a crowd."
My sister is right
here, and I said, no no.
And why did I say that?
Because I'm still stuck
five years ago.
This book "Becoming
Nicole: Transformation
of an American Family" as I hope
you know, or you're just here
because you're curious
about the title,
is about a transgender
identical twin.
Four or five years ago
this book fell into my lap.
I didn't think, hey I want to
go and write about transgender.
It was December 2011 when the first
article about the family appeared
on the front page of
the Boston Globe.
At that time Marty Baron,
now the Washington Post executive
editor was the executive editor
of the Globe, a very
far seeing individual.
It was really one of the
first major A1 stories
about a transgender child.
I remember reading it and
being fascinated by it.
And a couple weeks later I got
an email, someone I hadn't seen
in 30 years, a lawyer who
happened to be someone I had known
from a former life in Boston
when I was an academic.
And she was now representing
the family in a lawsuit
against basically the Maine Human
Rights Commission in the state
of Maine and the school
that was discriminating then
against fifth grader
Nicole who was not allowed
to use the girls' bathroom.
The family had been inundated with
press after the Boston Globe story.
And they're very protective and
they didn't want to do anything
but they realized that this was
a big response, that this was a,
you know, maybe important story that
they would want to tell eventually.
And they thought, maybe in a
book, something that would come
out when the twins had
graduated from high school.
I had just written, a
book had just come out.
I just won the Pulitzer so
my name was in the news.
So, this lawyer said
"Hey, I remember her.
She's written a book."
So, this fell into my lap and
I remember saying to my agent,
this is a fascinating story,
but who's going to want
to read a book about
a transgender kid?
So, the timing of this
book obviously that it came
out when things were building
in 2014 and early 2015.
It was supposed to come out
in early 2016 and they said,
can you get it out in October, 2015.
We didn't want to miss the moment.
We didn't know the moment
was going to continue.
So, this book, the twins right now
are entering their sophomore year
in college at two different
branches of the University of Maine.
And this is a family about
as ordinary as you can get.
And at the same time,
utterly extraordinary.
A mother who when her identical
twin boy was expressing at the age
of two, not the desire to
be a girl, the belief--
I will say he because
it was he at the time.
The belief that he was.
So, his question to his
mother and his father were,
"Well when do I get to be a girl.
When will my penis fall off?"
You know, and so, couldn't
fundamentally understand
that people were treating
this child as a boy
when he knew she was a girl.
Wyatt was a girl.
This is a mother, very
practical, very down to earth.
These were adopted
children from birth.
The only two things were
important to her were
that her children were
safe and be happy.
And that is what drove this mother
to figure out what was different.
Not wrong, not bad, not odd.
Just simply, you know,
different from her other child.
And she began the way a lot of
people begin with questions.
She googled.
Boys who like girls toys.
And that sent her on an odyssey
of trying to understand Nicole,
was what Wyatt changed her
name to before the fifth grade.
The father, very traditional,
conservative, Republican, hunter,
you got the moose antlers in
the room, and all of that.
It took him longer.
He had certain expectations
and beliefs.
And it took a while
for him to get it.
It took the court case
probably for him to get it.
He now goes around
the country talking
about transgender kids
and especially parents.
And he's particularly interested in
talking to men about their children
and trying to understand.
So, I wanted to actually talk a
little bit, the most important thing
to me actually are questions.
This is what I've discovered at most
of the events where I've spoken.
I have to say the last
event that I spoke
at was the Mid-Manhattan Library, I
probably shouldn't have outed them.
Very nice people, it
was a crowd of about 30.
That was good.
But, there was, it was a man already
asleep when I walked into the room.
So, thank you very
much for staying awake.
If you are from the
Mid-Manhattan Library, my apologies.
So, where were we 50 years ago?
50 years ago, in November,
November 21st 1966.
The New York Times ran
this small single column,
far bottom right-hand
corner of page one.
The first sentence read, "The Johns
Hopkins Hospital has quietly begun
performing sex change surgery."
What I love about that
sentence is the use of quietly.
You know, I mean what an
editorial decision to put--
why not, has begun begun
performing quietly?
It was already a sense
of shame involved in this
that even the New York
Times was reporting this,
you know, with some hedging to it.
Later in the story there's this
paragraph, "Psychiatrists believe
that transsexualism is caused
by prolonged conditioning early
in life, perhaps within
the first three years.
Some cases in which a mother wanted
a daughter, instead of a son,
and raised her child
accordingly seems obvious,
but the origin of others
is obscure."
So, that was in 1966.
Things weren't better
really by the '70s.
1977 there was an academic
study about an anecdotal story
that they thought might be useful
because of psychological
intervention instead
of surgical intervention.
And it was about a
successful exorcism
of a transgender individual.
Even in the front lines of feminism,
that we have sentences like this.
"Transsexuals are paying an extreme
tribute to the power of sex roles.
In order to set their real
human personalities free,
they surgically mutilate
their own bodies."
That was Gloria Steinem.
Now, Gloria Steinem and I share
an alma mater, Smith College.
She's a lovely woman and 30 years
later she apologized for that
because it took, it
took a generation
and a half to understand more.
And a lot of where we've gotten
to has been because of science
and now hand in hand with brave
people who are willing to come
out culturally to say who they are.
So, where are we now?
Okay.
There are, let me see there, 108--
just this year 187 bills have
been attempted to be passed
to limit the rights,
discriminate against transgenders.
Everything from religious exemptions
to government employee exemption,
to wedding services,
pastor protections
so they don't have to
marry transgenders.
187. The good news is,
only six have become law.
The large majority are dead.
There are a few that
are still active.
But at the same time, there are
dozens of states, 49 in fact,
and not 49 states but 49
bills have been passed that,
that do limit some small
rights to gender identity,
regarding gender identity.
So, obviously, we're in the
middle of of a controversial time.
But here's what I learned
in writing this book.
I'm a reporter.
I had to educate myself.
I had to do months and months and
months of research and science
and interview doctors
and endocrinologists.
And at the end what I realize,
when I write the sentence
"Gender is a spectrum," it's not
a politically correct phrase.
And it's kind of nice and sort
of rainbow-y and all that.
It is the case that
gender is a spectrum.
Frankly, as are most things
in life, we think binarily
but we don't live that way.
And we are not that way.
Look at the variety in this room.
So, you know, this is
where, this is an assumption
that I had made oh spectrum sure,
but, you know, when you think
about it, there are 10
trillion cells in the body.
There are 3 billion base
pairs of DNA in each cell.
There are 20, 25,000 genes
associated with those cells
that are either switch on
or switch off your genes.
Gender identity is just one
tiny fraction of all the things
that make up a human being.
And yet we already know, science
tells us, there are some people
who are born XX, some
XY, some XXY, some XYY.
There are people born with
androgen insensitivity.
There is no one cause
of transgender just
as there is no one cause of gender.
There are multiple factors
that go into gender.
A lot of people ask me,
obviously, and this is one
of the fascinating things about
this story, they're identical twins.
How could it be?
Well, we also know that identical
twins are not completely identical,
right?
They don't move exactly the
same, or think exactly the same.
They're bizarre cases where
they're separated at birth
and they do strange things,
you know, and they've named,
they've married the same
woman with the same name.
But by the same token, identical
twins you've met them probably
who have very distinct
personalities.
And the reasons for that is
something called epigenetics.
We're not just our genes.
We are the proteins
that code those genes.
We are the proteins that switch the
genes or the off that more androgen
in at a different time or less in.
So, what I came to realize
was that transgender,
as many things, is
not about aberration.
It's about variation.
And this was, this
was an insight to me.
So, we're not talking about
the acceptance of a disorder.
We're talking about the
acceptance of differences.
Differences that for years and years
and years people kept in the closet.
Right? So, when I wrote
this book, I got a letter.
If you subscribe to the Washington
Post and you read it avidly,
as I'm sure all of you do, then
perhaps you read earlier this year,
I think it was earlier, yes
earlier this year, the story I did
about Kate and Linda Rohr.
Kate Rohr was known as
Bill Rohr for 70 years.
Bill was married for 47 years
when he came out to his wife.
His beloved wife, they were
high school sweethearts.
Adored his wife, orthopedic surgeon,
accomplished, wrote many articles.
They adopted a couple of children.
As Bill, he adored his wife Linda.
But he always identified as a girl.
And like Nicole, at the age
of three, and this is back
in the '40s I guess, he remembers
thinking why do people refer
to me as a boy?
Why am I wearing boy's clothes?
So, once again, it
wasn't that I think--
and look for some kids it's in
between and they're not sure.
But these are two cases of
people who absolutely knew,
I don't think I'm a girl.
I know I'm a girl.
But it took this woman, who at this
point was a happily married man
until the age of 67.
And when he finally told
his wife after she said,
"You seem so happy lately."
Because had actually been giving
himself estrogen injections
and she wanted to know.
She was afraid he seemed so happy
that maybe he was having an affair.
Had no idea.
And he finally decided he had kept
this in the closet all of his life.
He didn't have a secret life.
He didn't, you know,
dress in women's clothes.
He didn't, none of that.
He had kept this hidden
all his life.
He said that he was transgender.
And they talked all night.
And she cried.
And she cried not because she
was disappointed or stunned,
she cried because she couldn't
believe that this person
that she loved had spent the entire
of his life, her life in such pain.
They will be married
50 years next year.
They are going to have
a recommitment ceremony
as Kate and Linda Rohr.
And the story came out.
They were very worried about it.
No one else knew.
Everything has been very--
it couldn't have gone better.
And so, you know, Kate says,
Kate who used to be Bill says,
"This just couldn't have
been done 10 years ago."
And that's true.
So, on the one hand we're at
a remarkable place in history.
When we got to gay
marriage, I never thought
that would happen in my lifetime.
But, the speed of which
change is happening,
I believe is a testament frankly
to the young people in our society.
And maybe even to the internet
where we are exposed to everything
out there, the good and the bad,
but also all variety,
all types of people.
Kids today know people.
If they don't know them
directly they know them online.
They know what it means
to be transgender.
So, we're at an important
place in history.
Because our laws I think
are trying to catch
up with this wave of sentiment.
And, this is a family that
can help to tell that story
because they are like you and me.
They're your mother and father,
your sister, your brother.
When I first met them, I couldn't
believe how open they were with me
and honest they were about
what they knew and especially
about what they didn't know.
About their flaws, and
about their change.
This is an everyman family.
This is an every woman family.
And the other thing that I loved
about them was that everything
about each of the members of this
family turns gender on its head.
Wayne, who had to undergo the
largest transformation the biggest
transformation will cry
at the drop of a hat.
It's very hard to do
interviews with him
because then he starts crying
talking about his wonderful family.
And then I start crying and
I said Wayne, please try not
to cry during this interview.
And it never works.
Kelly I've now known
for four or five years,
I'm not sure I've seen her ever cry.
She is down to earth,
practical, she is hard nose.
She is a mother bear
who has protected her kids
and is still doing it.
Nicole, this beautiful young
woman 18 now, you know,
very expressive personality.
She's an alpha-female.
She's you know, very
feminine, and yet loves, loves,
loves violent video games.
She just can't kill
enough people online.
Right? And she freely
says about her brother,
that he's incredibly sensitive.
That he's much more, Jonas
is much more in touch
with his sensitive side than she is.
Jonas likes to write
poetry, he plays the guitar.
He's also gotten in trouble
his freshman year in college
because he was dating two girls
at the same time and
they didn't know it.
But please don't tell
anybody, right?
So, this is a family everything
about them teaches a lesson.
And it was frankly without them
even knowing it that they were.
I feel blessed and I feel privileged
to have been able to
tell their story.
I have to say that a lot of the, the
credit for the book goes to Wayne
because he was an obsessive
saver and organizer.
He's a safety and security officer
at a university, the
University of Maine.
And he saved every piece of
artwork the kids did, every grade,
every psychological report, of
course all of the legal filings.
Hundreds of hours of video
that I watched, and I'm talking
like really boring video.
But boring video that
was very telling.
I saw a lot of video
of them at bath time.
And it was fascinating.
It was fascinating to see how long
Nicole, then Wyatt would stand
in front of the mirror kind
of puzzically [phonetic],
puzzling trying to almost to sort of
figure out what she was looking at.
But it also means that
I knew everything
about their lives beginning with the
video I saw of the twins in utero.
In utero where one of
the technicians wrote
after identifying the sexual
anatomy on the twins, still a boy.
Now I didn't, it's not clear what
twin the technician was writing
that about.
But, it goes to sort of underscore
that in a way language matters.
And our language has been
stuck in this binary.
I was talking to these wonderful
women, who are signing for us,
and I was asking them what
is the sign for transgender.
And there's a couple of
different ways of saying it.
Saying it.
But one sign is the heart.
The heart or change of heart.
And there's the other
one is, help me out,
saying-- writing it out trans.
And this one [inaudible] woman
was saying she's not crazy
about the change of heart
because it indicates
like a change is taking
place and it has more to do
with changing your anatomy perhaps.
This other young woman is
more comfortable with this
because she thinks
it's about the heart.
It's about who we are.
So, it's also about how
we interpret language.
Right? It's about the words we
use, but it's how we use them.
Okay. And even when we're trying
to figure out how to sign it,
it's fraught with difficulty.
You know, Nicole once said to me
that that stories breakdown the
walls that need to be broken down.
And I think that it
was the most profound,
one of the most profound statements
that she's ever, ever said to me.
Honor Moore, the poet, also once
said, "We don't choose our stories.
Our stories choose us.
And if we don't tell them,
we are somehow diminished."
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
So, please, there's a lot,
I'm hoping there's a lot
of questions out there.
Hopefully that I can answer them.
Yeah, please.
Questions.
>> Well, thank you for your
presentation and your work.
You mentioned the curiosity
about how two identical
twins could be different.
And you mentioned how
we're more than our genes
but we are in fact our genome.
And-- .
>> Amy Ellis Nutt: Our epigenome.
Yeah.
>> Clearly, yeah, and
clearly obviously,
you're also a student of history.
>> Amy Ellis Nutt: Yeah.
>> In the sense that you looked
at how sexual orientation
and particularly how we think
about transgender folks has changed
over the last 20, 30, 40 years.
And I know that you're
in the session just
previously with James Gleick.
>> Amy Ellis Nutt: I was.
I asked a question.
>> So, I'm wondering if
you can be a time traveler.
And I'm wondering if you can given
the emergence of biotechnology,
the possibility of
genetic engineering,
gene editing, yada, yada, yada.
What do you see?
What can potentially you see
20, 30, 40 years ago in terms
of how we might not only
consider sexual orientation by
but also perhaps manipulated
through biotechnology.
>> Amy Ellis Nutt: It was funny.
I thought you were going to
ask me to go into the past
to see how we accepted
people in the society-- .
>> [inaudible] we're always
looking at [inaudible].
>> Amy Ellis Nutt: Right,
and the societies that did.
Look, you know, Chris Bird's
genetic engineering's still very
controversial, and very new.
You know, and it all goes back
to what we started discussing
20 years ago in designer babies,
you know, can we identify
early things.
And I just think, yes, if we can
prevent diseases things like that
and that are going to
shorten a person's life,
then we need to do those things.
Do I think there's going to
be identification in utero
that a baby is getting
less androgen a male?
I don't know.
I think, I think there's, it's
sort of like when, you know,
10 years ago when we
thought, oh we're going to,
we're going to find
the schizophrenia gene.
Right? But we didn't find it.
You know, it's a whole lot
more complicated than that.
And I think that's also the case
of gender, and gender identity.
Look, there was a study that
was done recently looking
at there are a couple of two
or three different structures
in the brain that on average
are different between men
and women, on average, right.
One has to do with the
release of hormones.
It's usually twice as
large in men than in women.
And this study was done looking
at thousands of brain images.
And it actually found that
between a third and a half of all
of those brain images had a
co-mingling of male, typically male
and typically female
brain structures.
A third to a half that only between
0 and 8% had all typically male
and all typically female.
I mean what is a typical
male and a typical female?
Right? I mean it gets back to that.
When I say spectrum, I
really, really mean it.
And I don't think we can say,
here we are and then here we are.
We are a spectrum.
So, I'm not sure that there's
anything that we should
or could do in the future.
I do know in the past, that
there have been societies
and there still are who believe
that there were three,
four, five genders.
Most Native American tribes
believe there were multiple genders.
Many Asian societies
and cultures do as well.
So, yes? Oh, I'm sorry yes.
[Inaudible.]
>> Thank you for that
image of a spectrum
with respect to transgender.
I mean it's new to me
in my experience I think
of Christine Jorgensen which was I
think the '50s first sexual change
operation and that was
like black and white.
And now the idea of the
spectrum is sort of opening
up my mind and thank you for that.
So, my question is
within that context,
at what point does a difference,
I won't use the word deviation,
at what point does a
difference become a human,
a protected legal human right?
>> Amy Ellis Nutt: Oh, a
protected legal human right.
You know, we have a bill of rights.
We do not have a bill of non-rights.
You know, our Constitution
was about figuring
out everybody we need to protect.
They couldn't possibly foresee
transgender, right, 300 years ago.
So, it's about inclusiveness.
It's never been about
excluding someone.
It's always been about including who
are the, you know, the discriminated
against populations
that need rights.
One of the fascinating
things about doing this book,
is I talked at length with
Paul Melanson, the man in Maine
who waged a kind of
one person battle along
with the Maine Christian
Civic Union against the Maines
and against this idea of allowing
Nicole to use a girl's bathroom.
And he kept saying to me, and I
appreciated that he, you know,
answered all of my questions.
But he kept saying, it was about
giving someone extra rights.
They weren't like,
he had his rights,
and other people had their rights,
but these were like extra rights.
And it was something that was very
difficult for me to understand
because essentially it comes
down to you're getting
something that I'm not getting.
But I don't think that's it.
You're getting exactly what I have.
You're being protected in a certain
way for a certain way you are.
That's all.
So, you know, I think our
great difficulty in life,
if it really comes down to it, is
that society favors conformity.
Nature favors diversity.
Pure and simple.
Yeah, I know.
I know. I know, when I like
thought of that I was like,
oh yeah, yeah you got it.
But, yes?
>> Hi, thank you so much -- .
>> Amy Ellis Nutt: Hi.
>> For your book.
So, I'm a scientist and I was
very interested in Dr. Spack.
>> Amy Ellis Nutt: Yeah.
>> He was trained by
the Dutch, I believe.
>> Amy Ellis Nutt: Yes.
>> Is that correct?
A lot.
>> And I just couldn't
understand exactly why
from a scientific perspective
the Dutch refused to do anything
until I think, or no I'm sorry.
In London, they refused to do
anything until you're 16 I believe.
>> Amy Ellis Nutt: That's right.
>> And I wondered if you dove
into that at all in your research?
>> Amy Ellis Nutt: Yeah.
You know, I think that's something
that the Dutch are just
obviously an advanced civilization
and they're ahead of
us in so many ways.
Except they're crazy bicycle people
and you could get killed
if you're not looking.
But I think, you know, I'm
not so, I'm not as much sure
as it's a totally scientific reason
as it is this belief that children,
when are children grown up?
When do they have the
mental capacity
to make a decision for themselves?
And of course, I mean, I wrote
a book about the teenage brain.
We now know that the
teenage brain is still,
it's only 80%, you know, developed.
It's not fully wired
until the early 20's well
into your, you know, late 20's.
So, all those people who
have kids still living
at home, this is the issue.
Their frontal lobes are
not completely wired yet.
You can go home and tell them that.
But it is in part determining
when is someone able
to make that decision?
If it's the case that they want, you
know, gender affirmation surgery.
And I think what we've done,
at least in the United States,
is we've gone to, it's how
far are you willing to go.
We go to very long lengths.
The ability to, to delay puberty
has been critical in this regard.
Absolutely critical.
There's a big difference
in transitioning before
you've reached puberty
as opposed to post puberty.
Especially for girls,
especially for young boys
who identify as, as female.
You know, to have your face
enlarged, the hair, everything else,
it takes a lot of surgeries.
We know this, you know, by some
of the celebrities out there.
But if that's done before puberty,
if your puberty can be suppressed
and can be delayed until
your about to enter puberty
of the sexual anatomy that you
are born with, then there's time
for the person to go through all
the psychological tests to also live
as if it's a transfemale
to live as the transfemale.
To find out if that's
exactly what's comfortable.
And then to be able to start taking
estrogen instead of, you know,
allowing male puberty to take over.
And the consequences
of it are dramatic.
I urge you, and I'm sorry that
I don't have a presentation,
but if you go online and
look at the photographs
of Nicole, she's gorgeous.
Right? And she's, you know, about
five inches shorter than Jonas.
And she's, she's all female.
You know, it's, it's so much more
difficult later in life to make
that physical changes and if
that's what you decide to do.
So, I'm not so much, I'm not sure
it's, I do believe that the ability
to delay puberty scientifically,
medically has been key
to allowing children as
young as 16, now 17 or 18.
It's still typically 18, to,
you know, change their gender
at that point, if that's
what they decide to do.
Thank you.
>> Hi, I would like to tell a
brief story really quickly just
to frame my question.
So, you said two things
that really jumped
out to me in your introduction.
One the power of language and two
that it's taken a generation or two
to get to where we are today.
And that's the junction of those two
things have been a really big part
of my experience.
I have a sister who's a junior,
she's a senior at Grinnell College.
She founded an alliance program
in our high school and she's very,
very active about the
transgender, LGTBQ community.
And then I have two parents who
are kind of struggling to engage
in conversation with her about this.
There was a time when we
were out to a family dinner
when my sister was explaining
that she identifies as queer,
which the terminology has
changed substantially.
And in my parents' generation that
was a very negative thing and it was
like trying, I was sort
of that middle ground
to watch two people speaking a
different language understand
each other.
>> Amy Ellis Nutt: Yeah.
>> I was wondering if you could
speak to any guidance or advice
about sort of two ends
of the spectrum in terms
of understanding this issue
and how we can communicate
and not an aggressive, not a
militant, not an angry way.
But like really engage in
mature conversation about it.
>> Amy Ellis Nutt: You know,
I'm not sure I have any specific
advice except to talk about it.
And maybe to begin the conversation
with let's define our terms.
You know, when you, when you said,
you know, that she identified
as queer, I'm a, I'm sure
your parents' generation
where queer was usually
derogative, a derogatory sorry.
But, I was at a recent reunion,
college reunion and I was sitting
with a bunch of students and we
got talking about queer studies.
And I said please explain
to me what it is.
And it was eye opening.
Okay? I didn't know, you know,
it's about variation essentially.
And so, it was, it's important,
we have to, we not only have
to define our terms, we
often have to redefine them.
And so, I think it's important when
you have discussions like this is,
let's sort of lay out the
language first, let's make sure
that we're talking
about the same thing.
And this is what I
want you to understand.
And, you know, if it's
about listening and trying
to understand not about judging
and not about trying to match it
up to your own expectations.
I mean one of the reasons
I say this in the book,
I think one of the reasons that
Kelly was so successful as a parent
and she is the hero of
this book, is that she grew
up in a very dysfunctional home.
Right? She was given up
for adoption by her mother.
She left home at like the age of 15.
Kelly had no expectations of what
a perfect family looked like,
or what a perfect kid looked like.
And I really think that that lack of
expectation freed her to allow her
to look at her children
as you tell me who you are
and let me help you be that person.
Yeah.
>> Hi. Some people claim
that transitioning transgender
children is merely an attempt
to erase or make more mainstream
people who would have grown
up to be butch lesbians
or feminine gay men.
How do you respond to that and
when you were doing your book,
did you research at all the radical
feminist view of transgenderism?
>> Amy Ellis Nutt: To answer the
latter question first, not really.
It wasn't a part of the book
necessarily, but the first part
of your question is
very, very important.
And it was something that
I didn't mention first.
And one of the things that I
realize and I understood was
that gender identity
is completely different
and a completely different
brain process
in development from
sexual orientation.
They are independent.
Those are two different
things that are happening
in utero and at different times.
Our sexual anatomy is set
as six weeks in utero,
our gender identity
is like at six months.
I can't remember when
sexual orientation is,
but it's a different brain process
happening at a different time,
which is why because I
was initially confused.
Transgender people, are
they gay are they straight?
You know, but because it's sexual
orientation is simply different.
And it goes to our
understanding of variation.
So, I think it's a mistake
to think that, you know,
that to conflate the two.
I also think there's a, there's
a obviously there's an important
discussion happening with feminist.
Look, I grew up, I came of age
in the '70s, you know, feminism.
You know, Gloria Steinem and
everybody after her and Mary Daly,
and, you know, all of those women.
I think one of the mistakes and one
of the sort of knee jerk reactions
of some feminists right now,
and it's understandable,
when they see celebrities,
Caitlyn Jenner out there
who are super feminine and
who talk about their shoes
and their dresses and, you know,
being feminine, that it's a bit
of an affront to people who say,
well do they really understand
what it means to be a feminist?
Or what it means to be a woman?
But, here's what I
learned from a different,
from another transgender
person who at the age
of 40 was still wearing
like Mary Jane shoes.
She was a transfemale,
and I said Jennifer,
what the heck is it
with these shoes?
And she goes, "You know, Amy,
it's I'm still just going
through puberty still."
And then it occurred to me,
for a generation now of people
who unlike Nicole are unable
to transition at the right time
in life, there are many, many
transfemales for instance
who are transitioning in
their 40's, their 50's.
I know someone in their
early 80's who recently did.
And so, when they transition,
they are essentially
going through puberty.
And so, I think, I think
it's necessary for us
to give them a little slack.
To let, to let them experience,
the let them go through that.
Will we look to these people,
then, to address these issues
and what it means to be a woman
and to join in women's rights and,
you know, the need for, you
know, wage equality and all that?
Yeah. Absolutely.
But I think we have
to wait for that.
Maybe I'm a softy but.
Yes?
>> I just want, thank you for this
book and her adding to our knowledge
of this particular issue because
I know when my sister in law
came out when she was
a sophomore in college
and we were very strange
conversation.
I thought to myself, well she's
lucky to be born into this family
because this is a family that will
accept her no matter who she is,
what she does, you know, whatever.
But it's been a difficult,
a difficult road
for the family as well as for her.
And I just, I think to show
that it can be done-- .
>> Amy Ellis Nutt: Yeah.
>> In these mainstream families
because there isn't a
more mainstream family
than either Nicole's
or my sister in law's.
>> Amy Ellis Nutt: Right.
>> It's just small town America.
And it seems as though
you can't open a newspaper
without finding another story.
So, this wouldn't be possible
without the publicity
that these stories get.
And so, it's pretty
amazing what's happened in,
just in the past decade.
>> Amy Ellis Nutt: It is.
And you know, I think fear
comes from foreignness.
And so, the more people who are out
there saying "I am transgender,"
You know, this is what it looks
like, what it sounds like.
I think it, you know, it diminishes
our, you know, the barriers we have
to understanding something as
being, you know, foreign to us.
Thank you.
Yeah?
>> Yeah, so I have
like 20 questions.
I only have the one, so I think
the most pressing question is-- .
>> Amy Ellis Nutt: Yeah.
>> Is that, not just one
person is transitioning.
There's family, friends.
They're all transitioning, so at the
end transwoman transman they are--
this is the most selfish
thing you're doing to our life
because to be selfish is necessary.
So, the question is, how do we
relate to our friends, our mates,
our kids that what is
going on, you know,
only 10% of married
couples stay together
within six months of hormone HRT.
So, what's your advice to?
>> Amy Ellis Nutt: Wow, I'm not
sure that I have advice on that.
And you know, not being
transgender I can't really speak
to the experience.
But from the people that I've
interviewed, you know, look the Kate
and Linda Rohr who are still
together after 47 years of marriage,
did it make a difference that Kate
came out as transgender at the age
of 67 as opposed at the age of 37?
Or even 27?
Probably. They still
had an active sex life.
So, but it was, but what she, what
Linda knew was I love this person.
I have always loved this person.
But what she had to learn
as accepting as she was
because they adore one
another and always have,
what she had to mourn
the loss of Bill.
And I think that that was
something that she learned
and I think she tries to
get that message out there.
But she was losing something.
She was gaining something
and she still had something.
And Kate at first was, you
know, didn't quite get it.
But then she did.
She had to mourn the loss of
a certain way she had been,
or her belief about this
person that she was married to.
And I think, you know, grieving
over the loss is the beginning to,
is the beginning of
acceptance of what you have.
And, you know, you meet this couple
now and they're like little kids.
I mean, they're joyful.
You know, Linda gave Kate
on Valentine's Day a
cute little sexy nighty.
You know, and this was like, yeah.
You know, and a bracelet and she
had to take her out to Macy's
to learn how to do makeup.
And, it's a whole new world
that's opened up to her.
And now because they're sort of
out, new friends, and experiences.
And it also for her, for this long
marriage it helped explain a lot
of the mysteries.
The mysteries of when Bill
delayed trying to have children
because he was petrified
he would have a child
that would inherit
whatever it was that he had
and have a tortured life.
And she could never understand it.
Because on the one hand he loved
kids and he wanted a family.
But then he kept putting it off,
putting it off, putting it off.
Or the depressions.
He left her for a few months
because he had to work things out.
She didn't know what that was about.
So, a lot of the mysteries
of their marriage,
of this wonderful marriage
were all cleared
up practically in an instant.
And that was a gift too.
To be able to fully understand
this person that she loved.
I mean, it beings in love.
If we can remind ourselves of that.
That that is where it begins.
There are some people that
will not be able to get
over that hurdle of the change.
But I believe, I believe
that there's hope
that more and more of us can.
And that if we allow each other the
time, you know, and the conversation
to understand the changes going on.
You know, then we can do it.
Nothing stands still.
God help us.
You know, lives are short.
And if we understand that I
think that there's a great chance
that we will embrace what previously
we thought was unthinkable.
Well that's a wrap up I think.
See I'm so short I
couldn't see the time card.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Great questions.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.